[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy con la
segunda de 12 entrevistas para entender
la situación política de bolivia ya
conversamos con diego pary embajador
boliviano ante la onu y ex ministro de
relaciones exteriores en el gobierno de
evo morales y hoy nos acompaña
óscar ortiz ex ministro de economía en
el mandato de jeanine áñez gracias por
estar con nosotros señor ortiz hablamos
de la detención de la ex presidenta
interina jeanine áñez y la y de la
institucionalidad en bolivia cuando años
estaba en el poder la fiscalía acusó a
de morales de terrorismo y ahora que
regresa el gobierno de izquierda la
procesan por golpe de estado y también
de terrorismo que sucede dentro de la
fiscalía boliviana que dice también de
su imparcialidad
gracias por esta oportunidad y
obviamente lo que ustedes informan
refleja de que no tenemos un sistema de
justicia independiente no tenemos un
ministerio público institucionalizado
que garantice debidamente los derechos
de los ciudadanos bolivianos y que los
mismos puedan estar seguros que si son
acusados cualquiera puede ser acusados
pero van a ser procesados frente a un
tribunal independiente lo cual no existe
en el país en el caso de la presidenta
ya línea y hay una situación más grave
aún porque ella fue detenida sin
notificación previa sin ningún tipo de
citación que se hubiera realizado y como
recientemente el ministro de justicia
afirmó alguna declaración le han armado
un caso posteriormente a ser detenida
además por un motivo en el cual todo el
país sabe que ella no tuvo participación
como fueron todos cómo fue todo el
conflicto que se generó posteriormente a
las elecciones del 20 de octubre de 2019
que ocasionaron por las producciones
fraude electoral y la confirmación de
este fraude organismos internacionales
como la belen europea una serie de
movilizaciones y conflictos sociales que
obviamente no fueron liderados por el es
ahora ministro usted le mencionaba muy
bien sobre la oea existe una tensión
entre la oea y el gobierno boliviano
tras la detención de jeanine áñez el
organismo ha rechazado las amenazas de
la cancillería contra luís almagro a
quien señalan de injerencia colonialista
pero no fue el propio gobierno boliviano
quien invitó a la oea para hacer un
observador de los comicios 2019 donde el
organismo argumenta que ese que se
detectó un fraude electoral a favor de o
morales
efectivamente fue el estado boliviano el
que invitó a la voy a hacer la
observación electoral la firma del
convenio ley sobre personalmente o
morales con luís almagro aunque existe
un titular supremo electoral que es el
que vio haber hecho esa firma pero
además de ello posteriormente a las
elecciones diferentes a todos los
conflictos que se suscitaron los días
siguientes por la interrupción del
cómputo y las denuncias de fraude
electoral el propio de morales y el
señor para que habló con usted
anteriormente solicitaron a la oea una
auditoría de ese proceso electoral y ese
informe de auditoría ha corroborado ha
comprobado que hubo una manipulación en
los resultados para evitar que el ex
presidente evo morales fuera a una
segunda vuelta electoral ahora cómo está
trabajando la oposición frente a todo
eso están ayudando a reducir la
polarización a bolivia y tratar así de
llegar a un fin de esta crisis política
y social que vive el país
es muy difícil reducir la polarización
cuando en el mismo gobierno el que está
promoviendo la con estas detenciones
absolutamente inconstitucionales
impropias de un estado de derecho y con
una serie de medidas que están tomando
que básicamente lo que hacen es
profundizar la división entre los
bolivianos resquebrajar los pocos que
tenemos de institucionalidad democrática
y de nuestro estado de derecho 30
segundos para terminar a su juicio que
puede hacer el presidente luís arse para
tratar de salir entonces esta crisis
política
bueno lo que tienes que hacer es
reorientar todas estas actuaciones al
marco del estado de derecho de que como
han pedido la comunidad internacional se
debe liberar a la presidenta ya línea en
todo caso si se la va a procesar a
garantizar se le que lo haga en el marco
de todo un debido proceso y obviamente
en la libertad no tiene por qué estar
detenida cuando no hay todavía un
proceso del curso ex ministro ortiz
gracias por estar aquí con nosotros en
france 24 un placer y un gusto haber
conversado con usted de ustedes también
gracias por estar presentes en nuestro
segmento de entrevistas de cinco minutos
con hasta una próxima oportunidad
[Música]